As of this recording, almost a million of
you watched my chat with Jordan Petersen and
Ben Shapiro last week on YouTube, and a few
hundred thousand more of you have listened
to the audio podcast.
While mainstream media continues to spoon
feed the masses soundbite clickbait, we're
doing some real proof of concept work right
here to prove that you are a lot smarter than
they think.
While mainstream focuses on Trump's diet coke
habit we're here talking about the marxist
roots of postmodernism and the secular and
religious arguments over where rights come
from.
I received a slew of emails from you guys
about Jordan often saying things that go over
your head, but then you pause the video and
do some research yourself.
I'll be totally honest with you, sometimes
he says things which fly by me as well, and
while I usually try to pause him to clarify,
obviously I can't always do that in the midst
of the conversation.
While you're learning through these conversations,
know that I'm learning right next to you.
After the Peterson / Shapiro livestream, Jordan
got in a well deserved nap and then spoke
to a sold out crowd of 2000 people at the
Orpheum theater here in LA.
Jordan was nice enough to let me introduce
him as a surprise to the audience and I gotta
tell you it was truly the best reception I've
ever received.
I did a couple minutes of stand up, cracking
jokes about lobsters and the importance of
cleaning your room, but there was something
beyond just the laughs that I could feel on
stage.
The room felt lit with intellect and curiosity
-- 2000 strangers coming together to hear
a middle aged psychology professor talk about
how fixing yourself is the only way to fix
the world.
This simply wouldn't have happened even two
years ago because so many of you who dare
think differently were silenced by false cries
of racism and bigotry.
People like Jordan and Ben are using their
intellect to say what they believe and that
in turn is showing millions of people out
there that they can do the very same thing.
Whether you like or hate Trump, this idea
revolution is directly because of his election.
Everything is up in the air right now from
our political institutions, from the to our
educational institutions to our media institutions.
As Eric Weinstein and I discussed a few months
back, perhaps some of us would've preferred
less upheaval to get us to address the problems
with these institutions, but perhaps that
more selective, tactful upheaval never happens.
As I said to Eric, he wanted a panther in
a china shop, but all that was available was
the bull.
As the Rolling Stones taught us, You can't
always get what you want, but you get what
you need.
As most of you probably have seen already
we followed up our chat with Peterson and
Shapiro with the Brothers Weinstein, Eric
and Bret.
It was their first public appearance together
ever and I have to say my brain is still in
recovery mode from taking in so many high
level, important ideas.
If the dial of ideas was turned on low for
the last few years it is quickly moving into
the hot position.
The dial is moving because the conversations
we're having here are finally starting to
leak out into the rest of the world.
That's why thousands of you are showing up
at Jordan Petersen events and at live Sam
Harris podcasts.
And by the way, Sam and Jordan disagree on
pretty much everything, especially the most
fundamental existential questions that exist.
Yet we're all on the same side because the
only real enemy is the authoritarians who
want controls so they can have us silenced.
Once you realized that, you suddenly will
find yourself with many more allies and many
less enemies.
So it probably goes without saying that I'm
feeling incredibly positive about the direction
things are heading and I hope you are too.
This month, we're going to continue having
real conversation with people who are really
affecting the world with their thoughts and
their actions.
We've got a 5 time bank robber who became
a Georgetown Law professor, a former head
of FEMA, and a nuclear power expert running
for governor of California.
Also I'm thrilled to share with you that we're
also doing 5 shows in 5 days with 5 experts
on 5 different presidents of the United States
to celebrate Presidents week.
From some founders like Jefferson, Adam and
Madison to JFK and to Lincoln, the stories
of our past are as relevant as ever as we
fight for the liberty of today.
Oh, and yes, we'll be doing plenty more of
the 3 person sit downs as well.
Who do you want sitting across from each other
let us know in the comments right down below.
After all, there's a Idea Revolution happening
right now and it may not be televised but
it's definitely going to be streamed...